cuál es el enésimo término en la
siguiente serie de temática 37 + 11 15
19 etc
estás edición incrementa con una cierta
cantidad fija cada vez pensamos en ello
el primer término es 3
y lo vamos a incrementar en 4
aquí vamos a escribirlos esta serie 3 7
11 15 19 etc
entonces a este 3 le agregamos 4 y se
convierte en 7 a 7 le aumentamos 4 va a
ser 11 si a 11 le aumentamos 4 va a ser
15 y si a 15 le aumentamos 4 va a ser 19
y así sucesivamente así que esta es la
cantidad que se va a agregar viendo esas
opciones quizás nos veríamos tentados a
pensar que a pues es 4 por m lo que
vamos a agregar pero no es lo que está
pasando para la primera vez n va a ser
uno entonces 4 por 1 va a ser 4 y no va
a ser 3 esta opción es incorrecta sin
embargo si seguimos analizando si n es
24 por 28 7 es menor que 8 así como este
3 fue menor que 4 para m igual a 3 3 por
4 12 11 es menor que 12 y es menor en
una unidad
ahora veamos quién es igual a 4 4 por 4
16 15 es menor es 16 en una unidad
entonces vamos a ver no es esta opción
ésta es incorrecta pero estamos viendo
que si se está cumpliendo siempre y
cuando restemos una unidad cada vez
entonces nuestra función que nos define
esta serie aritmética va a ser 4 n menos
uno tienes 14 x 14 menos 13 de este
valor tienes 24 x 28 menos 17 de este
valor
si en es 33 por 412 menos 1 es 11 y así
estamos viendo que se está cumpliendo
con esta serie así que esta es nuestra
respuesta correcta veamos el siguiente
problema qué expresión representa f dg
de x 7x es igual a x cuadrada menos 1
x es igual a x 3
vamos a acostumbrar a estos problemas
suelen ser divertidos tenemos que es
efe
de x esto significa que en fx en esta
función f x cada vez que yo encuentre
una x lo voy a sustituir por lo que dice
x
entonces esto va a ser igual aquí hay
una equis en esta fx aquí hay una equis
entonces aquí voy a sustituir gx al
cuadrado menos 1 y egb x que es a pues
es x + 3 bueno puede sustituir esto aquí
donde debería ir mg x
x
al poder ahora vamos a desarrollar esto
esto va a ser igual a equis cuadrada
+ 6 x
9 - 1
que es igual a equis cuadrada 6 x 9
menos uno es igual a 8
esta es mi respuesta y veo mis opciones
y que creen aquí está en la opción b esa
es mi respuesta correcta veamos el
siguiente problema número 72 dado que fx
es igual a 3x al cuadrado menos 4 y gtx
es igual a 2 x menos 6
es gdf dedos
aquí nos están dando un número que
podemos calcular el valor de f2 vamos a
sustituir este 2 en fx
efe de 2
cada que yo veo una equis voy a
sustituir un 2 va a ser igual a 3
x lo sustituyó por 2 al cuadrado menos 4
esto es igual a 2 al cuadrado es 4 3 por
4 12 menos 4 es igual a 8
y este 8 lo puedo sustituir en gx pues
este es el valor de f2
así que gdf x que es 8 para ser de 8 es
igual a 2 por 8 menos 6 que es igual 8
por 2 16 menos 6 es igual a 10
este es mi valor d
gdf de 2 y es mi opción aquí está muy
bien veamos el siguiente problema si fx
es igual a equis cuadrada más 2x más 1 y
gtx es igual a 3 por x más 1 al cuadrado
cuál es la forma equivalente de fx más
gx ya que lo que nos piden es sumar a
más funciones me piden sumar fx
que lo voy a poner en un color
gx así que voy a escribir los términos
de cada una de estas funciones
fx es x cuadrada + 2 x
2 x 1
x es 3 x x 1 al cuadrado esto lo tengo
que desarrollar lo voy a hacer de una
vez
x + 1 al cuadrado
y hacer tres post
x más un al cuadrado es x cuadrada
2x
+ 1
y ahora pues voy a desarrollar esto ya
simplificar esto lo voy a distribuir en
todo lo que se encuentra en el
paréntesis 3x cuadrada 2 x 3 6 x 3 x 1 3
y dejo estos otros términos en verde que
estos no los modifique x cuadrada + 2 x
+ 1 + esto y ahora voy a agrupar los
términos similares
x cuadrada 3x cuadrada va a ser igual a
4 x cuadrada 2 x 6x esto va a ser igual
a 8 x
y ese término solito 13 es igual a 4 4x
cuadrada más 8 x más 4 esa es mi
solución y vemos las opciones es la
opción c esta es mi respuesta muy bien
vamos con muy buena velocidad ahora
veamos el siguiente problema
un profesor de matemáticas distribuye
aleatoriamente 15 reglas con etiquetas
de centímetros y 10 reglas sin etiquetas
cuál es la probabilidad de que la
primera regla que entregué tenga la
etiqueta de centímetros y la segunda
regla que entregué no tenga etiquetas
pensemos en la primera opción donde
preguntan la probabilidad de que es la
primera regla que entregue tenga la
etiqueta de centímetros
tenemos un total de 25 reglas 15 con
centímetros y 10 centímetros así que
nuestro total es de 25
y sólo 15 reglas tienen etiquetas de
centímetros
solo 15 de ellas esa es la probabilidad
de que la primera regla tenga
centímetros
esta es la probabilidad de que la
primera regla
tengan
etiquetas tiene etiquetas de centímetros
con etiqueta
además de que la primera tenga etiquetas
nos preguntan que la segunda regla la
segunda que entregué no tenga etiquetas
así que es esto por la probabilidad de
que la segunda regla no tenga sin
etiquetas
sin etiqueta
y aquí es el truco que además siempre y
cuando la primera haya tenido etiquetas
la primera en entregarse primera con
etiqueta etiqueta
lo cual puede parecer muy complicado con
la anotación pero intuitivamente debe
tener sentido pues una regla ya fue dada
y tuvo etiqueta así que cuántas reglas
me quedan si ya digo una regla de las 25
pues me van a quedar 24 reglas esto lo
multiplicó por algo entre 24 reglas que
son las que me quedan y cuántas de estas
no tienen etiquetas bueno la primera
tenía etiquetas así que aún me quedan 10
reglas sin etiquetas así que son 10
si nos pidieran otro caso en el que la
segunda regla también tuviera etiquetas
entonces tendríamos 15 entre 25 por 14
entre 24 porque ya habríamos usado una
regla con etiqueta por lo que esa
cantidad se decremento pero aquí tengo
una regla menos pero tengo completas las
reglas sin etiquetas simplificamos esto
para no hacer esta operación tan
grandota este 15 lo puedo dividir entre
5 y me queda 3 este 25 lo puedo dividir
entre 5 y me queda 5
tres quintos
este 10 lo puedo dividir entre 5 y me va
a quedar 2 3 por 2 es igual a 6 entre 24
y esto lo simplificamos y nos queda que
es igual a 1 entre 4 que es la opción a
un cuarto de probabilidad de que suceda
esto y ahora pasemos al último problema
de este vídeo
en cierto día la probabilidad de lluvia
es de 80 por ciento en san francisco y
30% en firme asuma que la probabilidad
de lluvia en las dos ciudades es
independiente cuál es la probabilidad de
que no llueva en ambas ciudades nos
preguntan la probabilidad de que no
llueva en san francisco
la probabilidad lo multiplicamos por la
probabilidad de que no llueva en sydney
entonces cuál es la probabilidad de que
nos lleva en san francisco
bueno aquí nos están diciendo la
probabilidad de lluvia así que la
probabilidad de que no llueva pues va a
ser el complementario a este va a ser
20% o punto 2
y la probabilidad de que nos lleven sin
y si la probabilidad de lluvia es 30% la
probabilidad de que no llueva es el 70
por ciento es decir punto 7
esto por 0.7
hago la multiplicación
7 por 2 14 más los dos lugares decimales
aquí tenemos el punto así que hay una
probabilidad del 14% de que no llueva en
ambas ciudades
nuestra opción ve nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo